What do you know about the American Civil
War?
Just saying these words — “the Civil War”
— probably brings some familiar images to
mind.
Northern soldiers in Union blue marching against
Southern troops in Confederate gray.
Epic battles at Shiloh and Gettysburg.
Abraham Lincoln’s Emancipation Proclamation
and the end of slavery.
The victory of the Union over the Confederacy.
But there’s something else you should know
about that era — something that ties these
events together, and that you probably didn’t
learn in school.
The Civil War was also America’s greatest
left-wing revolution.
Here’s how.
In the early nineteenth century, African slavery
was the foundation of social and economic
life in the American South.
Millions of black workers were owned as property
by wealthy plantation owners, who denied them
education, controlled their family lives,
and reaped the fruits of their labor.
This system was wildly profitable, and the
wealth it produced allowed a tiny elite to
dominate Southern and national politics.
And before the Civil War, it was expanding
across the Western Hemisphere.
In 1860, between the United States, Brazil
and Cuba, there were more enslaved people
than ever before.
For years, a small group of American abolitionists
denounced slavery as an abomination.
These radical activists were scorned by much
of society, and ignored by both of the two
mainstream political parties.
But in the 1850s, as slaveholders tried to
extend slavery across the West, their opponents
made a breakthrough.
The old two-party system melted down, and
the new Republican Party won massive Northern
support by opposing slavery’s expansion,
while putting bondage itself on a road to
“ultimate extinction.”
The abolitionists broke through, in part,
because they named “the Slave Power” as
the oppressive ruling class it was.
They pointed out that slaveholders were just
1 percent of the population, but controlled
every branch of government.
They argued that black bondage was not just
morally wrong, but a threat to free labor
everywhere.
The struggle between antislavery and slavery,
said Abraham Lincoln, was part of “the eternal
struggle” between “the common right of
humanity” and “the divine right of kings,”
“the same spirit that says, ‘you toil
and work and earn bread, and I’ll eat it.’”
It was the common worker, black or white,
against the rich.
These populist assaults on the ruling class
helped Lincoln’s party win the election
of 1860.
Contemporaries called it a “political revolution.”
Its threat to slaveholders was so serious
that they formed their own separate republic,
the Confederate States of America.
In the Civil War that followed, the stakes
were clear.
The Union fought against human bondage, for
a democratic majority, and for the dignity
of all labor.
The Confederacy fought to preserve bondage
and elite rule.
Confederates fought, as Lincoln told Congress
in 1862, to put “capital” — wealth,
measured in human beings — “above labor
in the structure of government.”
Enslaved laborers understood these stakes
— hundreds of thousands fled to the Union
lines even before emancipation was proclaimed.
Radical abolitionists knew it too: Frederick
Douglass barnstormed the country, rousing
black men to enlist in the Union army.
By war’s end, around 200,000 black soldiers
and sailors had taken up arms to crush the
rebellion.
The cause of the Union was the cause of the
international Left.
While conservative aristocrats and capitalists
in Europe sympathized with the Confederacy,
radicals and labor organizations supported
the Union.
In 1864 a German journalist named Karl Marx
declared that “the American antislavery
war” would launch “a new era of ascendency”
for “the working classes.”
Emancipation, as Marx understood, was not
a middle-class reform project: it was a true
social revolution.
Only in the United States and in Haiti was
emancipation sudden, uncompensated, and enforced
by former slaves themselves.
That revolution remains incomplete.
After the war, former slaves and radical Republicans
were defeated by what the scholar W.E.B.
Du Bois called “a counterrevolution of property,”
led by former slaveholders and conservative
businessmen.
Under the terror of Jim Crow segregation,
many of the Civil War’s victories for labor
and democracy were rolled back.
But not all.
The destruction of American chattel slavery
was a historic victory.
It meant that black southerners were able
to create the schools and churches that seeded
the fight against Jim Crow.
It radically expanded American democracy and
made the modern labor and civil rights movements
possible.
The Civil War was America’s greatest left-wing
revolution.
Even now, its work remains unfinished.
But every left-wing struggle — for the rule
of democratic majorities, for the rights of
labor over property, and for meaningful freedom
and equality — can claim its legacy.
I’m Matt Karp, associate professor of history
at Princeton University, for the Gravel Institute.